Hello and welcome to this video on the different modes which are available within Unreal Engine.
We're just going to be looking at a couple of them quickly so that you're aware of them.
If you want to learn more, there are other courses which cover them in detail.
Now to change mode, you'll see that there is a drop-down in the top left-hand corner
of the editor.
This will allow you to either select the mode manually or it will show you the hotkeys required
to jump to this mode.
And that's Shift plus one of the number keys.
By default, you will be in the selection mode.
This is what will allow you to manually select and move items around.
Next up, we have Landscape.
Now the landscape mode is designed so that we can create a large mesh for the landscape.
It will be divided into different segments.
When you first load it up, you're going to see this wireframe green grid.
They will indicate the size of the landscape that you are about to make.
Now you can either generate this from a height map by importing a file or you can just change
the settings and create the landscape yourself.
Now I'm going to hit the Create button to create it.
And that will then create the mesh.
And we'll see where the cursor is.
We now have a blush.
You'll see that we come onto the center tab.
It's part of it that's called Sculpt.
This will allow me to use the left-hand mouse button to sculpt the landscape.
I can hold down Shift and that will make the landscape go down.
It will allow me to create a landscape.
There are also a number of other brushes that are available to you.
For example, erosion.
This will try and simulate physics to how mountains would erode over time,
giving you a more realistic look.
That looks quite good.
Now there's only so far you can go with sculpting the landscape
before you're going to need a material to be attached to it.
So I have a very simple material already set up in this example.
So I'm just going to add that.
Now I'm going to come onto the third tab for Paint.
And it has the material applied.
So I'm going to go create layers from the assigned material.
And I have to also create some supporting files.
So this gives me two different layers which I can now paint with.
So for example, I have a very simple grass which I'm going to cover most of this with.
And
I could also paint in a mud layer.
So we create a muddy section down the center here.
Now this is very simple.
Good landscape materials would look a lot better.
This just sort of demonstrates the workflow.
So that is landscape.
It allows us to sculpt a landscape and gives us the option to paint it
inside the texture.
To complement landscape, we have the foliage tool.
Now what the foliage tool does is rather than in selection where you manually place a static mesh
actor, the foliage allows you to paint foliage onto a landscape.
So you can paint multiple meshes and they'll use something called static mesh instances.
Which are more optimized than a static mesh.
As far as demonstrating this quickly by one that I previously made using the trees.
And select that, you can now see that I can paint the trees onto our landscape
just by using a brush.
This is a lot quicker and more optimized and manually inserted.
Next up, I'd like to have a look at the modeling tool.
And what the modeling tool does is this gives us functionality within the engine
that you would expect to find in a modeling program such as Maya or Blender.
Now we can create meshes.
We can change their UVs.
We can bake textures.
We can remesh them and do a lot of things inside here.
It is a quick demonstration.
This I've created a box.
And I'm coming into the modeling tool.
Select the main face and then select insert will allow me to create an insert except.
And now I'm going to extrude the middle, push in and accept that.
So now I have created a mesh box which is has an inside open.
But just shows you how you can quickly create models or adapt models inside of the engine.
Next up, I'd like to show you the fracture tool.
Well, what this is is this works with our physics engine called chaos
that allows us to do things like destroy boxes and create realistic explosions and build some things.
So let me quickly look at this.
So what I'm going to do is I've selected the box.
I'm going to add new geometry collection.
And I'm going to then fracture this geometry collection like this.
Push fracture and see if I push change the explosion amount.
We can see how this is going to smash up.
So we've got our fractured box.
I'm now going to just drag this higher up, rotate it slightly on one edge.
I'm going to select the geometry collection.
Change the damage threshold so it's very low.
So you can see that this box has broken as it's broken.
Now again, this can get a lot more complicated and you can make a lot more impressive
explosions and destruction that it all comes under that mode for fracture.
The other modes that we haven't touched on include mesh paint.
Mesh paint allows us to paint onto a mesh into the vertex data
and then use that within materials.
Brush editing.
This is useful for gray boxing out level.
And animation.
So this mode gives us some supporting tools to use with our sequencer model
that will allow us to do things like this.
That will allow us to create and bake out animations.
Thank you for sticking with us there.
Those recovered all of the modes.
In our next video, we're going to be looking at some of the other
features that are offered inside Unreal Engine.